what's happened you bad [ __ ]
hold on the thing was [ __ ] up I gotta
hit you with a big cloud of smoke
oberlin shitty
there you go that's a [ __ ]
cloud what's happening baby Friday may
whatever the [ __ ] it is it don't really
matter cuz you're slinging dick and
giving our bubblegum you understand me
when that's the state of mind it's seven
days a week you swing and take it really
don't matter still recovering from the
marshal again I had vertigo yesterday
you know I like those when you do
mushrooms you get better gonna next day
those [ __ ] are kicking dog good
week of podcasting just getting crazy
again who gives a [ __ ] dog that's why
it's a podcast we don't want it to sound
like [ __ ] radio and okie dose on
there well this happened to me get the
[ __ ] out here but besides all that it's
Friday you dirty [ __ ] Memorial Day
weekend summon the troops I just banged
my [ __ ] head off this brick wall by
mistake but it don't matter it's like a
concussion bringing me back inside the
don't matter cause we got the reefer I'm
dead today
smoke in the [ __ ] XJ from perennial
green and we got this [ __ ] death left
over here tried it [ __ ] I don't know
where you're taking I got shipped into I
got a meeting I'm gonna make this field
go to jujitsu I got a thousand [ __ ]
things going on time Blaine stop in
planning auto God's last night I had to
cancel the store in the last fact I was
shooting late my apologies if you went
down there but besides that uncle Joey's
ready to rock today its Fridays one more
day we can salute the mother [ __ ]
Flag you see a veteran you see a [ __ ]
so do you hug that mother [ __ ] you give
a big butter weed and you say you go
[ __ ] you deserve this oh [ __ ] it's
mad flavor bringing out death on to
[ __ ] legs in the standing
look at this look at the colors in this
[ __ ] I'm gonna blow your [ __ ] wigs
right off position
there you go oh we're gonna see the
devil together today Friday who gives a
[ __ ] was smoking to your token
understand me I don't give a [ __ ] listen
take a weekend off do what you gotta do
eat somebody's ass hole something thick
whatever you do do let me tell you
something when you come back on Tuesday
your pin point mugu you understand me
you understand I'm kind of see you
forget it all out we're going back to
basics and [ __ ] smoking push-ups running
in the dark it don't [ __ ] matter i
gotta get ready for my special october
15th and rosemont st. easier there you
square you understand me I'm getting the
training started in omaha nebraska in
two weeks then I go to Philadelphia then
I have no surgeries orchids smell again
so I can smell some [ __ ] flats and
the essence of a [ __ ] monkey what
else do I got we got [ __ ] Oklahoma
this sunlight at Denver this summer I
got Nashville with summer yeah so we're
gonna be working out the [ __ ] special
I got one night a month of lapis do ten
dollars showin to you who long just to
run the hour you guys are my [ __ ]
judges do a couple rows at the [ __ ] I
sounds and that said people I'm just
playing this [ __ ] down so
October 15th I'm like a [ __ ] animal
lot they understand me
a map you guys I got your back then you
got my back does it feel [ __ ]
goodness ain't about money this ain't
about this that there's that there's
about two [ __ ] soldiers
together now it together as a family
understanding but Joey enough with the
chitchat I know I'm stoned to the gills
ah let's throw this [ __ ] bolt cutter
2 times you got big [ __ ] going on next
week but you got talent when you have a
holiday these [ __ ] Gentiles a week to
before the holiday then mine goes to
[ __ ] it won't cut potato salad oh my God
we're gonna go to lydia's I'll give a
[ __ ] I lift with to the hell they know
I'm no [ __ ] tomorrow all i know is
today i means i'm gonna try to get a BJJ
in and that's it man i'm just trying to
[ __ ] go forward ain't no [ __ ] world
mast I'm just a fat [ __ ] trying to lose
weight and get limbo
dr. police's book breathe is working cuz
I'm saying my loans are stretching I'm
blowing out more [ __ ] smoke on get
higher than I've ever been
oh yeah are you [ __ ] lunch or what
this is it I'm not much to say its
knowledge no I love you mother [ __ ]
with all my heart and the next [ __ ]
couple months a little vacation for all
of us when we come back Tuesday control
over you [ __ ] why does I
something said so who's the captain kirk
of this [ __ ] enterprise flavor
[ __ ]
his little [ __ ] dust left yeah i'll
let this dust send this should have
[ __ ] you up mr. bottom of this I gotta
go back to perennial clay I'm gonna go
see the Russians I still now [ __ ]
stars left it's gonna be a phenomenal
[ __ ] weekend you understand
Oh
now that's a clock okay how are you
people like oh my god no no you'd only
have the same the [ __ ] vapor time can
do back your final had a favorite honey
we got my [ __ ] all the smoke got
[ __ ] the fire truck to come over you
have enough problems now smoking reefer
the factory barking comes over once a
month cuz they know what the [ __ ] is on
file v-very meliza as you guys have seen
those my podcast acid on the podcast
heavy duty free from the podcast why
everybody else is talking about it will
live in it for you understand me that's
the difference between flavor and all
these other Punk she's saying let's not
go my God he's so witty get the [ __ ] out
here I grew up in a [ __ ] box with his
mom freedom at it right the [ __ ] Yuda
[ __ ] [ __ ] America's in love with
now these guys are [ __ ] that
Americans are love you got a tattoo uh
it's a [ __ ] glass oh my God he's so
cool then why is a [ __ ] button a half
you don't even leave tipsy such a
[ __ ] mutt
get more how to read people better
that's the prom in America's get caught
up and lighting the same [ __ ] idiots
everybody else [ __ ] likes [ __ ]
morons I never liked bout it I see these
guys I see them [ __ ] they wake up
every morning and they should [ __ ] and
get up on the hands and knees and pray
to God thank you Lord for not let these
[ __ ] no I you're funny that's
what half these [ __ ] should do
but you know what I don't give a [ __ ] i
got a very bland smoke my refund I
talked to my [ __ ] Savage [ __ ]
Church people my brothers and sisters
and that's it we make the best of it so
do what you gotta do it's my bar then we
get the salute the soldiers get your
dicks under and that's it I'll see you
mother [ __ ] Sunday night we're doing a
special podcaster you wake up Monday
morning it dipped a loop with a [ __ ]
podcast beside that I love you mother
[ __ ] I'm stoned to the gills you did
your job today stay black and I'll see
you Sunday and I you never know we might
do one of these later and maybe tomorrow
morning [ __ ] you never know have a
great dental and nobody [ __ ] with you
today as a matter of fact they can all
suck your dick it's your [ __ ] world
flunkies punk-ass [ __ ] there's a new
kid in town [ __ ] here